hello everybody and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll today's guest
is dr. Anthony pin who's a professor in
the religion department at Rice
University now do not be alarmed despite
being a professor in the religion
department and in fact despite
describing himself as a theologian dr.
pin is an atheist a humanist that's not
to say that we will not occasionally
have actual religious people actual
theologians on the podcast but that day
is not today
Anthony pin has a very interesting
trajectory he grew up in upstate New
York where he was a child preacher so at
age 12 he was standing up there in the
pulpit preaching sermons bringing people
to Jesus and he was really good at it it
actually was quite the calling that he
had he went on to college in fact to
Divinity School but then along the way
he lost his faith he got the idea that
he was trying to help people in
underprivileged communities he didn't
really think that God was helping them
he didn't really think that his
Christianity was helping the cause of
bringing these people's lives to a
better state so he ultimately lost his
faith but he didn't lose interest in the
idea of helping people so he stayed a
self-described theologian but now he
tries to bring humanism
to people rather than Christianity and
in particular he tries to bring humanism
to the african-american community where
atheism agnosticism humanism are not
very popular if you look at different
demographic groups in the United States
I just looked it up only 2% of blacks in
the United States describe themselves as
completely atheist that's compared to
something like 6 percent of Latinos 11
percent of whites 19 percent of Asians
so somehow if you're an atheist you're
saying what are we doing wrong why
aren't we reaching these people if
you're Christian you might say what are
the African Americans doing right why
are they so much better at maintaining
their faith than the rest of Americans
are well I can't imagine a better person
to talk to about these issues than
Anthony pin he's the author of many
books I'm not for all this time all here
you can look them up on his web page but
a few of the more recent ones are when
colorblindness isn't the answer
humanism and the challenge of race the
end of God talk an african american
humanist theology and a very interesting
semi autobiographical book called
writing god's obituary how a good
methodist became a better atheist so
we're gonna talk about all these things
we're gonna talk about the time that
doctor pin taught a course at rice on
religion and hip hop to other parts of
human culture that you don't often hear
put together but it makes for a great
little stew of intellectual topics so
we're gonna have a lot of fun let's go
[Music]
all right Anthony pen welcome to the
podcast great to be with you so the
point that I'm trying to get across for
many of these podcasts the conceit if
you will is that I'm after the ideas
right the big ideas I want to kind of
figure out like how we can think about
the world how we can learn about it less
about people's individual
autobiographies or anecdotes and so
forth but I'm thinking that maybe we
should make an exception a little bit
you know sometimes you get to some big
ideas by personal autobiography right
sure sure so why don't we tell our
listeners a little bit about where you
started in how you got where you are
well I grew up in Buffalo New York very
much involved in the church started on
the path to ministry as a preteen and
moved through ordination so by the time
I was finishing my first year of college
I could marry Barry and baptize people
that was the youth pastor at a rather
substantial Church in Brooklyn New York
but I was struggling a bit I'd come from
a rather conservative Southern Baptists
high school a feeder program for
institutions like Bob Jones University
okay yeah we know well right let that
sink in yeah and so I get to New York
and I'm taking classes and of course I
thought I needed to major in religion
because I loved religion but I'm
encountering students and faculty who
thought of the Bible is simply a piece
of literature not necessarily very good
literature and so this was throwing me
and I'm encountering people who adhere
to a variety of traditions all of them
from my vantage point led to hell and
they were unapologetic about their
involvement it was throwing me for a
loop and I'm encountering young people
this is the early 80s I'm encountering
young people in in Brooklyn who are
having an easier time thinking about
their death than thinking about a bright
and productive future and what I could
offer them through my tradition amounted
to nothing and so over the course of
those four years I start I started
rethinking faith still committed to
ministry but rethinking faiths you're
working as a minister and also as a
student
- time right right right rethinking
faith but knowing I needed to get out of
New York City - can think through these
issues without the pressure of ministry
at my church people wanted me to have
answers not good questions just answers
they had enough quest or correct answer
yes yes yes and so I decided to go to an
institution that really didn't care very
much about ministry it was about ideas
and during the course of the Master of
Divinity program the professional degree
from ministry my thinking began to shift
and by the time I was a PhD student I I
realized I needed to make a decision I
could be a custodian of the tradition
and forget about the misery and the pain
that people encountered or I could move
beyond theism and and concern myself
with what people encountered on a daily
basis so I contacted the minister of the
local church I was involved with and the
Bishop of my denomination the African
Methodist Episcopal Church and gave my
resignation and never looked back
well and so this was at Harvard Yesi
school yes and when were you there
exactly I was at Harvard 86 through 94
okay so we overlapped I graduated with
my PhD from Harvard 93 right I would
have had I had almost no you know
connection with people in other schools
except for the Graduate Student Council
intramural basketball league that we
played basketball against each other I
played at the law school every Saturday
Oh but just pick up okay just pick up
they weren't formally there no no did
you play against Barack Obama a couple
of times you know did he like tell you
with him and go like this guy's gonna be
President someday well all of the buzz
about him suggested he was really
special right right so I'm at the
Divinity School and then the Graduate
School it's a school of Arts and
Sciences and everyone knew about him
yeah okay good that's what I didn't know
about him but I was in a different
moving in different circuits yeah so
okay so it sounds like you're you had a
journey from being a child preacher to
atheism
it was mostly driven by what we could
call practical concerns about your
ability to successfully minister and you
that was is it safe to say that's sort
of what
you into a change of worldview oh sure
sure that what I believe theologically
and what I practice religiously did not
line up with what people were actually
encountering in the world it did not
give me a way of addressing misery right
right so I always wonder because in
philosophical or theological circles we
debate whether God exists right we prove
that God exists or doesn't exist and
I've always thought that these debates
have essentially zero impact on people's
belief structures right like the reasons
why we actually believe for one thing or
another usually at least biographically
come from these more practical concerns
I remember a friend of mine and I taught
a course at the University of Chicago
for undergraduates on the history of
atheism and we were both atheist so we
we were a little worried we weren't
trying to proselytize right we wanted to
make the religious students in the class
comfortable and so we worried talking
about all these proofs or arguments for
and against the existence of God whether
people would get disturbed no no one
cares right it didn't make any impact
yeah but when we talked about how the
Bible had been written write the history
as you say and the Bible as a work of
literature some people got a little
upset like that was hitting them and oh
[ __ ] they hadn't really thought about
before oh sure yeah and and though I I
think you're absolutely right those
those debates only accomplished so much
because this theologia logical
commitments and and religious practice
our faith driven there's nothing
reasonable about this it's faith driven
and so even much of this evidence will
be used by theists to prove their point
right so for many of them who grew up
like I grew up even this rigorous debate
this this effort to tackle the faith
proves that they're on the right path
because the devil is out to get them
yeah it's a non falsifiable right
there's nothing that can happen in the
world where you would say well that's
how exactly devil would have arranged
right right right
but you I mean you felt mostly that it
wasn't helping right your your faith was
not actually giving you answers that
would improve people's lives in an
interesting and more certainly was not
because some of this struggle for these
young folks at first in Brooklyn
then in Roxbury where I ministered
before I left the church they are
literally dying right right crack
cocaine is taking them out yeah late
eighties early night yes and nothing
about church practice kept them safe but
they wouldn't have agreed right they
would have said that that was an
important part of their lives at the
time I think for some of them it was
cultural commitment this is what their
family did this was what black people do
on a Sunday but I think life for them
raised questions that they tried to push
to the side because of these other
obligations and in retrospect would you
say that if you you know as a PhD now as
a professor if someone asked you to
explain and defend your views of the
world your ontological views about the
nature of reality is it the same answer
or would you say did you come to atheism
for the right reasons or do you have
better reasons now I came to atheism for
reasons that made a tremendous amount of
sense and based upon the condition of
the world like the environment of which
we are apart and human life those
reasons are still sound right and you
are someone who is happy to characterize
yourself as religious although you are
as an atheist is that accurate
yeah and I've done that for a variety of
reasons as I initially moved into
atheist and humanist circles there was a
failure and have recognized what
humanism and atheism mean for some folks
right there are ways in which we were
reluctant to talk about the nature of
community and interactions right so
there was no real interest in talking
about ritual right there was limited
conversation concerning the wonder of
life and so I posed that initially to
break that stranglehold but and also for
me was a matter of this that I think for
humanists and atheists the real target
is theism not religion those two overlap
but they are not synonymous exactly
right so religion is a much more broad
expansive category than theism
almost certainly
and by opposing a thousand to theism
that makes sense but then if you say
that your atheism undermines religion
there's a lot of stuff left right a lot
of questions most certainly most
certainly because on one level it's
based upon a false assumption that all
religious people are theists right
I mean Nietzsche got this right right
you know he pointed out that god is dead
okay what are you gonna do about it now
I think a lot of atheists have this view
that realizing that our best scientific
philosophical explanations of the world
don't include room for God that was the
hard part and once we get that done then
now we can just be good people and
that's the easy thing I see it exactly
the opposite way around like that was
the easy part you know figuring out that
God doesn't exist yet now it's easy
2,000 years ago maybe not but what are
we gonna do about it leaves us a lot of
discussion yet to have right Oh most
certainly and he was right on target
Nietzsche was right on target right it's
not simply enough to take God off the
throne the challenge is can we leave
that throne empty right and we tend to
put in place of God other categories
that strangle us in very similar ways so
you're so well if you talk about
ontology what the world is made of at a
fundamental level you are fundamentally
you're not theist obvious right a
naturalist is that fair to say it's it's
fair to say but that question doesn't
occupy a lot of my time okay and so I
tend to do this in Reverse the question
for me is what's necessary in order to
make life productive what is the best
vocabulary the best grammar of life that
allows us to to flourish right and then
from there move to these issues of
ontology and so you're happy to call
yourself religious in the sense that you
think that there should be some set of
ways I don't know I shouldn't put words
in your mouth tell me like what does it
mean how do we replace the other roles
of religion other than saying that God
exists well religion for me is this I
think of religion as a strategy kind of
a way of interrogating human experience
so if we think about human experience
Ariane's for example less cookie dough
laid out okay religion would be that
Christmas tree shaped cookie cutter it's
a way in which we isolate certain
moments of human experience for
interrogation but it isn't substantive
so I've tried to move away from a sense
of religion as soui generous that is to
say I've moved away from a sense of
religion as something in and of itself a
kind of special experience no it's just
a way of interrogating human experience
and I think whether we're theist or
atheist we isolate and interrogate
moments of human experience mm-hmm and
your professor of theology and so you're
sort of happy to use words like theology
and religion now other people maybe even
myself would say look if you're using
words like theology and religion like it
or not people associate these words with
various connotations is it a little bit
dangerous to put ourselves in that
basket or is it is there more to be
gained by saying you know you can be a
religious atheist a religious humanist
my attitude has always been this that
there are there are elements of this
religious theological language that are
still productive elements that aren't
like God right right that language needs
to go away but there are elements of
that language that are still useful and
I'm unwilling to let theists just have
this right right being being loud and
persistent isn't sufficient claim to
this and so it seems to me there's still
something about this language that
allows us to remain open to the wonder
of life right and I something struck me
I was just in Japan a few weeks ago and
I was I've always been struck by
churches by cathedrals especially in
Europe you know the grand structures and
there's something about them some human
beings hit on a way to design a space
where when you walk in you feel
something and in Japan going to Buddhist
temples it's the same thing right like
some people across the world and would
you say that we have somehow seeded that
to
theists and maybe we should recapture
that try to you know be have a humanist
way of constructing these spaces but
should we even call them sacred or
transcendent what what is it oh can you
Larry we should use their I don't like
the vocabulary of sacred and secular
because I don't think there is an easy
split right and so I don't find that
those two terms particularly useful from
my vantage point I think humanists and
atheists have simply forgotten that we
construct these spaces it's not
Riverside Church it's MoMA yeah exactly
but we have these spaces that open us to
a different range of questions the the
big questions of life who are we what
are we went out with why are we we have
those spaces but we've forgotten to name
them I love that the University of
Pittsburgh they have the tall building
called the Cathedral of Learning yes
myspace I mean how much should humanists
try to more or less directly mimic the
practice of religion should we have I
know that some people have you know
secular weekly meetings right I've been
to talks by atheists small gatherings
where not only was there a sermon but
they passed around a collection play you
know like is this are we just making
excuses for not having all the wonderful
practices of religion or are these
things that we can hope to really
replace I think it's a mistake to try to
mimic these theistic ritual moments it
does not work well right
I think ethical culture and the UUA
Unitarian Universalist Association are
prime examples of how poorly that works
okay in part because it doesn't really
those sorts of services don't allow us
to fully recognize appreciate and act on
what is uniquely us right right what is
unique about our philosophy of life and
so I think the hard work is in front of
us and that involves developing ways of
celebrating community and ritualizing
life that speak directly to what it
means to be a humanist or an atheist as
opposed to taking something and
rendering it no longer Christian but
Christian light right that's right don't
just water down the existing things but
this is a you're asking a lot right I
mean how to build up a form of life
after we've removed a lot of the excuses
or justifications that we had for all
these practices we used to have is this
something is it working are people
actively pursuing this is it gonna
happen I don't think it's really
happening I think in too many circles
people confuse asking the questions with
doing the work right and so we felt and
recognize this so even the occasion that
brought us to Las Vegas the American
Humanist Association this is a
ritualized activity if we think about
ritual simply as repeated repeated
activity and found it's space right
right there's nothing magical about that
or theistic about it it's just people
getting together for a particular
purpose and doing this over and over
again this is what this gathering is but
we've kind of wiped out our ability to
understand this as our ritualizing of
life getting together that celebrates
community but how does it happen so is
it purely organic or should we be a
little bit more top-down about it should
we try explicitly consciously to invent
rituals or will they just appear III
think it requires some intentional work
yeah and and the question is how to do
that exactly and I don't know the answer
yeah okay but I I know it can't happen
if we aren't intentional about it I mean
universities are pretty good at it right
pomp and circumstance everal students
get their PhD hooding ceremony yeah
exactly those kinds of ceremonies so
you're suggesting that will be part of
how we you know recover these forms of
life that used to belong to religion or
to theistic religion we can still have
that oh sure but we first have to
recognize that theists don't own right
those moments they've utilized them
they've had really good
we are around them but they don't own
them and it seems to me this is also
vital if we are to grow this is one of
the questions I hear over and over again
why aren't we getting bigger and why
don't folks from this community
participate with us and why aren't there
more African Americans well we don't
give them a soft place to land they
already know theism doesn't work that's
why they're looking for something
different so a lot of atheists want to
give you an argument for God's not
existing and you've what you're saying
is you need a lot more than yes replace
what they're losing right and how good
has so how do we do it is it the
American humans Association or is it
talking on blogs where do you find these
communities I think for a lot of folks
they've gone online but again I don't
have the answer but I think I have a
really good question we ought to wrestle
with and and I think how this happens at
its best it kind of involves local
organizations local communities that are
able to address particular needs and
desires in real time as opposed to the
national organization saying well this
is what you need to do in Cleveland and
this is what you need to do in San
Francisco let local folks figure this
out there's no atheist Pope right
there's no right but what about so
someone might say look the rituals are
great but some people need the promise
of salvation they need to believe that
there's something bigger that comes
after this life what do we tell them
here is my thinking that we are already
involved in something that is bigger
than the individual we are individuals
within the context of communities and it
seems to me it's this recognition of
this larger thing we call life that
serves as the humbling moment for us
it's not god or gods it's the fact that
we are involved in this process of life
that is bigger than we are yeah I would
love to ask you sort of tough questions
about this but I agree with you so much
that I find it difficult you know I've
had people say to me without God without
something bigger than our lives here on
earth how can you find meaning how can
you find how does why does it matter
you're just gonna die
it's just you know chemical reactions
how can you possibly associate that with
something meaningful and I want to say
how else like what what else matters
this is the life really exactly exactly
and so I turn to people like Richard
Ride or w/e B Dubois or Albert Camus who
who provides strategies provide insights
on how you move through life without
those sorts of assurances right or what
Elbert Camus calls this kind of grand
unity and it involves the the deep
desire and the effort to make life more
comfortable to to provide healthy life
options for all right and kind of yeah
recognize that this involves a much
softer relationship with the world and I
know that you've also emphasized music
quite a bit I loved it in one of your
books when you talk about the Blues and
its relationship to secularism I never
really thought about it this way but I
think you make the point a lot of the
earliest blues songs were if not openly
secular than at least skeptical of the
religious traditions in which the
artists were singing is that right oh
there's an important fact to keep in
mind that for centuries it was illegal
for people of African descent to learn
to read and write and so for us to probe
this community and assume that their
humanism or their atheism is written in
books is just ridiculous they weren't
allowed to learn to read and write but
it doesn't mean they didn't think and
express themselves and so one of the
easier ways one of the vehicles
available to them was music and so we
can't accurately date the spirituals we
don't know when spirituals begin in that
same way
we can't accurately date the blues it's
a mistake to think in terms of the early
20th century and race records blues is
older than that and whereas the
spirituals are all about theism divine
forces breaking into human history the
Blues hold all of that suspect and the
Blues demonstrate a comfort with and an
ease with the the nature of life the
kind of messy nature of life and that
goes all the way up to hip hop is it
accurate
they certainly let me know you taught a
course and religion yes yes not on
hip-hop and humanism what what is the
difference there well with this course
there are several things I wanted to
accomplish one I wanted to get my
university to think differently about
hip-hop as a culture and and and stop
simply assuming that this is bad stuff
yeah right on one level that's mistaken
because while hip-hop artists need to be
held accountable for their their
misogynistic viewpoints and etc etc it's
a mistake to assume that they created
these problems hmm yeah they're in a
context right they came from a culture
you know look I'll admit when it comes
to hip-hop I'm a very old man like I
think that everything after Eric be
enriched I understand that the kids
today have their own artists that they
that they like very much and it is a way
of it's one way of finding meaning right
certainly and so what we try to do is
give a sense of the the interactions
between hip-hop and traditional forms of
religiosity Christianity Islam for
example but we also look at the ways in
which hip-hop culture constitutes an
alternate religious orientation but then
we also look at the ways in which
hip-hop critiques theism and embraces
something that's more humanistic in
nature so how does that happen give
examples because I'm really not familiar
yeah well so if you look at someone like
jay-z let's think in terms of jay-z and
Kanye West no church in the wild that
song dismantles all of the major sources
of authority in human civilization and
they also as part of that process bring
into question the utility of the God
idea and it's even more fully expressed
by jay-z and the track crown and the a
solo album that comes around the time of
no church in the wild and in that he
dismantles the idea of God and you get
something along these lines in it if if
fear is the only God than getting people
out of fear is his only job right he's
kind of dismantling all of this
and it's a much more materialistic
viewpoint or you get a Kanye West who
has a song I am a God right that just
kind of dismantled so much of what we've
typically thought about theism or even
if we move in the direction of the five
percenters right and think about hip-hop
in the five percenters well why don't
you explain more about what the five
percenter is well during the early 60s
there's a figure Clarence 13x in
Manhattan who has questions concerning
the Nation of Islam and his argument is
the Nation of Islam is not teaching the
truth it knows the truth but it's not
teaching the truth now he argues the
Nation of Islam argues that black people
are made in the image of God right they
they they have a direct relationship to
Allah but Clarence 13x argues no no no
the black man is God not made in the
image of God is God is that secretly an
atheist move there well I think it
certainly opens up it removes well if it
doesn't remove metaphysics it radically
alters what we can even mean by
metaphysics maybe it's a humanist move
is a fair way to say it right I would
think so yeah
and so 5% nation it's its name this
because they argue that that 10% of the
population let's think in terms the
Nation of Islam has truth but they don't
teach it right 85 percent of the
population just ignorant and they will
follow anyone who sounds good only 5% of
the population has proper knowledge and
these are the poor righteous teachers
the five percenters and five percenters
as you know right as a fan of Rakim you
know that the five percenters are big
within hip-hop culture but they provide
a very different way of thinking about
how theism functions at the very least
what you get with the five percenters is
a sense of religiosity that is grounded
in human history and within the material
world and a suspicion of authority in
some sense almost definitely what if if
if
they are correct and and the black man
is God who gets to tell god what to do
I mean is it accurate to say I think
I've read things by you that call into
question the common belief that back in
the day you know around the time of the
19th century lens day that African
Americans were so deeply embedded in the
Christian tradition that that's sort of
the only way they thought you want to
recover a little bit of a humanist
tradition even way back then that
assumption yeah you're absolutely right
that assumption just demonstrates that
the black church has had very good PR
right there something that black people
are part of the black church or they're
really not black right but if you really
give attention to African American
thought and life you get a sense that
there always been a variety of vantage
points a variety of systems of thought
of philosophies of life that have
competed and some of those strands are
humanistic if not atheistic in nature
and so part of my responsibility part of
my work has involved trying to surface
those for greater attention and
investigation to counter veil some of
the PR that the black church has been so
good at and to and to reclaim some of
these figures that they have falsely
argued are part of their camp so W EB
Dubois for example major figure you
cannot really think about race relations
in the 20th century without thinking
about his souls of black folk published
in in 1903 a major major figure but in
his autobiographical work he makes it
clear that he was not a believer
interesting I did not know that oh no no
he's not but it's nothing he's really
interested in arguing about but he isn't
a believer yeah you can easily imagine
that people would say like look I have
other battles to fight right now right
and maybe even up through the Civil
Rights Movement that kind of thing like
we need to come together believers and
non-believers because there's a crisis
that we're facing that is a little bit
more immediate and it's a false
assumption what what he argues in some
of his writings that that on a mundane
practical level the black church can be
useful it has
resource it has space but he's not
buying the theological claims and the
same with other figures like James
Weldon Johnson mm-hmm well I'm not
familiar with he's a fantastic fantastic
figure he did this book called God's
trombones and it's an analysis of the
black sermonic style the black style of
preaching and so black Christians have
assumed ah he wrote this he's one of us
no he understands the utility of this
sort of conversation understanding how
ideas get communicated in a rather
effective way but he wasn't a believer
in his autobiography he makes it clear
that as a college student he gave up on
God
a philip Randolph mm-hmm major figure in
the civil rights movement he's a
non-believer
he's an atheist but he maintained
membership in a church for the same
reason he maintained membership in a
union right that this is an organization
and it can be helpful in terms of
getting us organized but he didn't like
the theology right right and the list
goes on so no Hurston argued that prayer
was for the weak-minded well it's a
complicated history as far as I know
between atheism and humanism and race
relations generally right like some of
our favorite Enlightenment thinkers at
the dawn of the scientific age said
things about Africans and yeah it would
make our skin crawl a little bit now
right and they they have descendants
today who are a little bit less popular
or mainstream but this you know use of
secular reasoning science and so forth
as a tool for putting down black people
in Africans that goes way back so we
can't really say we humanists can't
really say we were right from the start
about that and we get the question wrong
I get this question over and over again
why are black people still Christians
when Christianity was used to enslave
when to enslave them when the better
question for us is why isn't humanism or
atheism more attractive to this
population and part of that will be you
know moving away from debating arguments
for fine-tuning in cosmology in the
existence of God too
living our lives better right exactly
exactly and so science extremely
important there's there's no reason to
debate that but I think it's also
important when we felt and we fail to
recognize this on occasion that even
scientists live within the cause and
within the context of cultural worlds
and these cultural worlds impinge and so
it's insufficient to say that there's
nothing real about race so let's not
even bother with it right because it has
real consequences it's a social category
that has real consequences just like
when death that's right in so this this
is getting to something I definitely
wanted to talk about because I know that
a lot of people in the Atheist secular
communities would like to say that our
goal should be to be colorblind right
our goal should just be to be pure
reasoning rational creatures
Universalists humanists and to just not
even notice when someone is white or
Asian or African American and that so
again I don't want the words in your
mouth I suspect you're gonna say that's
not at least a good medium term strategy
I'd say it's ridiculous and and I say
that for a couple of reasons one it
paints difference a problem to solve
when difference is an opportunity and
our strategy ought to be seeing
difference but not allowing that
perspective on difference to taint
populations but also it seems to me that
it is problematic not only because it's
poor thinking with respect to difference
but it allows whiteness to remain
normative right because what we end up
with are more shades of the same right
and and so what people are actually
saying it seems to me is you're okay as
long as I can see you through the values
the sensibilities to move through the
world that is mine yeah there's people
and there's people of color and yet this
it's it has to do with you know
psychology and how we view the world the
lens again another theme that I want to
emphasize over these podcasts is the
lens through which we view the world no
choice of focus I mean you can say many
many things that are true statements but
you're emphasizing some things and not
others and that's a really important
choice that effects what you think is
important or even the phrase people of
color allows whiteness to remain
normative right because the assumption
is this is everyone else it seems to me
a better phrase is people of a despised
color hmm it's a little more normative
there and people might worry about it
but yeah it gets at the point that that
is that is going on here I mean and this
gets us into a broader category that
goes beyond atheism and humanism there
are phrases that are very powerful that
have been used in this discussion like
identity politics white privilege and I
think that you know I can sense it in a
lot of atheists that phrases like this
make them uncomfortable like somehow
this is you know something that is being
worried about that I don't kind of want
to deal with so you know do you find
these concepts important crucial should
we rehabilitate them so we make sure
that atheists are cognizant of what is
going on in those levels almost
certainly and rethink discomfort that we
really can't make progress on these
sorts of issues with people remaining
comfortable that everything about these
conversations concerning race gender
sexuality class et cetera ought to make
us uncomfortable
and we ought to see that discomfort as
an opportunity to rethink re-engage and
put in place better strategies right I
mean discomfort is something that makes
people run away but I like it you're
saying that discomfort can be is always
I'm not quite sure a sign that something
questionable is being questioned yes so
I mean what you know sometimes I'm just
uncomfortable just because I think
people are wrong but other times it's
because I'm worried that my
presuppositions that have gone through
with life maybe
colored things in a way I wasn't
conscious of and it seems to me in both
of those instances the question is what
does that discomfort open you to do
right right and what so what should it
to rethink assumptions right that
perhaps what I've been thinking about my
engagement with issues of race or my
engagement with issues of gender maybe
my assumptions here are wrong maybe I
need to rethink maybe I need to listen
to what they're saying do a little
homework so how would you define white
privilege well first thing I would say
is we need to move away from the
assumption that it's only economic hmm
it's not just a the amount of money in
your bank you know nobody who is
critiquing white privilege is simply
looking at bank accounts although there
is that I read just very recently the
statistic in the Boston area
the median wealth of a white household
is about two hundred and forty thousand
dollars the median wealth of an
african-american household is eight
dollars sure and there's something to
this economic issue but that's that's
not all there is with respect to white
privilege so so even poor whites are
there's an assumption that what is
available within our society all of the
best that's available in our society is
rightfully mine I am entitled to this
and it gets played out in a variety of
ways I'll give some easy examples right
so it may be a matter of privilege if
you go into the restaurant and you're
seated near the restroom and your first
thought isn't is it because of Who I am
or you go to the car lot and your
thought is can I afford this car as
opposed to how much attention from the
police will this car get me right right
so there are ways in which this operates
that has nothing to do with the bank
account but the assumption that this
society is for me and certainly in the
news recently obviously the night last
couple years we've heard we've heard
more stories of african-americans being
shot and killed and at least in the last
couple weeks we've heard all these
stories about you know people calling
the cops on an African American because
they were walking down the street or
sitting in Starbucks or something like
that
presumably these stories have been
happening all along and we're just now
beginning to notice them this is a
feature of the attention to which we pay
to different things
I think that is that's certainly part of
it and and I think there are ways that
we're seeing over the past decade for
example different types of challenges to
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness right so a black male with his
child in a stroller in a park is a
threat to black men waiting for a buddy
in Starbucks a threat so even the
pursuit of happiness right this
occupation of space becomes problematic
and it so seems to me that if you think
in terms of most drastic instances death
or these these other instances of
disregard you are not entitled to this
public space all of this really speaks
to a sensibility on the part of some in
the United States that black life does
not constitute anything that needs to be
respected and there is no rightful
occupation of time and space for black
bodies and it can be hard for a white
person who thinks of themselves as
well-meaning well-intentioned they would
say look I'm not a racist and it can be
hard for them to appreciate right like
what the differences are that might be
very very subtle just from living your
life on it every day in an everyday way
because of the color of your skin right
the unspoken elements of privilege and I
think that as a scientist do you know
I'm a theoretical physicist there are
not a lot of african-americans in my
field there's a questions of what can we
do about that it's it's a very analogous
question to the misrepresentation of
gender in the field also and there are
definitely people out there arguing well
it's just a clear reflection of
underlying distribution of innate
abilities but there's other people who
might say you know we can't worry about
the representation of African Americans
in science because we need to just worry
about getting them out of poverty right
so worrying about getting physicists as
african-americans is premature right now
do you have feelings about this it seems
to me that because the issue is so
layered and complex we need a variety of
strategies so we do need better a better
representation of African America
and others in higher education but we
also need to start much earlier right so
we can't think about the benefit of
higher education as a way of breaking
for example the cycle of poverty with
high school juniors it's much too late
right we need to start with kindergarten
first grade and put in place and put in
place a different way of educating a
different way of understanding these
populations and encouraging them to
explore there's something about life in
the context of the United States that
wipes out curiosity for
african-americans and Latinos it because
curiosity can be dangerous
interesting so so even more so I think
that there's something that wipes out
curiosity for everyone who is in
elementary school but you're saying that
it's especially felt by people in these
people despise color communities and so
I would I haven't heard before you think
that this idea that just being curious
is dangerous I might have heard before
you know we don't have time for that
right like we need to work on earning a
living right but you're saying there's
sort of an active force working against
asking questions in the way that would
lead you to these more intellectual
academic pursuits
oh sure definitely and and it's harder
for us to recognize this now when when a
certain type of lynching was more
prominent the idea that curiosity kind
of moving outside of the accepted
boundaries could be death-dealing that
was easier for us to get but there's
still something about racial dynamics
within the context United States that
can make curiosity moving outside of
accepted boundaries really dangerous and
do we combat that with better role
models with more sort of more explicit
programs that you know secondary in
elementary and university education
levels like what's the what sort of the
strategy yes and more right because the
problem is so complex and layered we
need a variety of strategies and some of
these strategies have to involve
reinvesting in public education for exam
and kind of highlighting opportunities
that really encourage and reward
curiosity and but that's only part of it
it's only part of it right yeah and it's
there's something we can ask about what
individuals should do and something we
can ask about what organizations should
do and it goes back to your soft landing
question like how do we as humanists and
secularists create a way is it safe I
replace what the churches offer done III
would argue we need to do better than
these deserts yes on one level we should
not be holding people hostage right so
so at their worst churches have given
but with a stranglehold we're giving you
this but you better be a part of what
we're doing right we're giving you this
but only after you listen to the sermon
and you walk down that aisle we need to
do better than that and so on some level
we need to give people a soft place to
land but we need to invest in
communities and so in part this is why I
say this is the kind of work that needs
to take place on the local level so
local humanism and atheist organizations
need to look and ask the question these
communities were concerned with what do
they say they need right and then work
to provide that and could you imagine
working with churches in doing that I
think that is absolutely necessary for
us to partner with progressive theists
we're not going to make substantial
changes alone we know there were there
were slight controversies back in the
early days of blogs I remember about
whether or not atheists should partner
with churches on climate change right
because their people said look climate
change is important if you find someone
who's on your side who cares what their
beliefs about God are and others who
said well yes but beliefs about God are
also important and we're sending mixed
messages if we team up with them so
you're on the teaming up side yes my
argument is this we can maintain the
awareness that on the philosophical
level we disagree right but in terms of
and so we might disagree with what
motivates our ethics but if we can agree
that
have to do something and we can commit
to sharing our resource to get that done
why not yeah very good what do you think
about sort of the tenor of conversation
in the country these days I don't want
to get too much into president and so
forth but resentment of minorities of
people of color of immigrants and so
forth does seem to be a feature of
certain parts of our political discourse
number one what can we do about that
number two what can humanists in
particular have to say about that
first thing I'd say is we have to
recognize that this isn't new right that
this sort of disregard is extremely old
it's manifest in different ways now but
the underlying animosity has been in
place it has been in place right right
difference has troubled us right and so
I think on one level humanists and and
atheist organizations need to commit
resource to making a difference and and
this means and of recognizing from my
vantage point recognizing that if we are
not concerning ourselves with issues of
justice a broad range of issues of
justice than we are actually part of the
problem it's interesting that the phrase
social justice warrior has taken on for
gorge of connotations right do you would
you be happy to call yourself a social
justice warrior sure yeah sure I my
humanism doesn't make sense to me if it
doesn't continuously remind me that the
world and people are suffering and what
do you say to people who would say well
I shouldn't worry about other people's
personal problems and fitting in in this
society people should help themselves up
right like what we should do for African
Americans is let them succeed on them on
their own rather than trying to help
them up after I stop laughing I'd say
I'm not very good asking these questions
from the point of view no no I know I
get it but it's not a level playing
field and the fact that we had a black
president for
years doesn't change that it is not a
level playing field and so we need to
put in place strategies programs
opportunities that reflect the fact that
it isn't an even playing field do you
have a point of view on what is you know
there's the standard question of what is
motivating these Midwestern voters who
flipped from Democrat to Republican over
the last few years I mean some people
want to say that it's inequality it's
economic anxiety others will just point
right to racism or fear of immigrants or
resentment what's your point of view on
that my initial response Maya nishal
response was why are people voting
against their own interest but then it
hit me that on some level they might be
voting against their economic interest
but what they are doing is safeguarding
their social stance is their social
standing right so they're willing to
forego political political advantage
economic prosperity for the sake of
being able to say whiteness still
matters do you think that's explicit or
it's sort of behind the scenes in their
minds I think a little bit there are
instances when it is extremely explicit
but I would argue for the vast majority
it's it undergirds their thinking and
their ways in which they may not be
aware of it but that's the power of this
social construct called race we don't
have to talk about it anymore it's just
assumed that's its power yeah and it's
the thing that to a leftist a liberal is
always surprising is that people in
disadvantaged circumstances somehow see
that they're disadvantaged or that
they're low down on the economic ladder
and they choose to blame other poor
people rather than blaming rich people
and it seems I'm not an expert on this
in any way but it seems that race and
nationality and ethnicity
work as proxies to make this happen
right in a way that is its kind of a
fundamental issue for democracy to deal
with right it's not just the United
States it's around the world different
democracies are sort of being threatened
by the fact that a lot of people are
resentful and want to become more tribal
and he's not and and I think there's
this element of what those who hold the
vast majority of the wealth are saying
about themselves and others right and
those who look at them and say ah that's
what it means to be successful if these
successful people are saying it's these
other folks who are keeping you from
getting ya their success
kind of wins the day it's and it seems
to me there's something akin to this and
the prosperity gospel movement so take
someone like creflo dollar who is
extremely wealthy and his argument is
well the problem is you're you're not
following the strategy it's all laid out
in Scripture there's opportunity that
you're not maximizing and people buy it
against the physical evidence because
this person who has everything they want
is saying this is the case and it seems
to me that this has happened on a larger
scale in the United States those who
have are pointing the finger and those
who want by it in some sense yeah I mean
Donald Trump is rich he must be on the
right track right and III worked for him
I've tried to understand how someone can
read the New Testament and come away
thinking that somehow it is glorifying
material success ah see but here's your
mistake you're assuming that Christians
are actually reading that's possible I
mean but there are always for every line
that as far as I can tell for every line
in the Gospels where Jesus says
something like being poor is better than
being rich there's an interpretation
right there's a hermeneutics that that
says what he actually means is rich is
better it's a it's a it's a wonderful
testament to the cleverness of
theological thought mm-hmm most
definitely and as this is this are
allowed to you know critique hip-hop
than the same sure standards like there
is a glorification of mature material
success oh yeah I mean there's and in
that way hip hop is extremely American
and outlook and again my argument would
be that we need to hold these artists
accountable for the ways in which they
contribute to problems and so I have no
issue with that
my concern is when we assume that they
are the source of the problem right that
there was no sexism until hip hop right
right no misogyny until hip hop do you
see it changing do you think that hip
hop is evolving in that way I think hip
hop has always been complex right and
and so it seems to me that there it's
always been layered you you've had a
more aggressive dimension of hip hop
that understood that that drugs for
example are the way to success right
that this is the way to achieve the
American Dream and they celebrate that
and you get elements of hip hop that are
about social critique right a Public
Enemy about social critique and and
rethinking the system so I think these
elements have always been present and
now you have in the mix Pulitzer Prize
winner
Kendrick Lamar who has a really complex
depiction of life in the u.s. so just to
close this the last topic let's be a
little bit more philosophical I know
that you said and I get it that you're
less concerned about metaphysics and
ontology and more about the lives that
we lead but ok there's a connection
right so you know back in the day if you
wanted to lead a good life you could ask
yourself what does God want me to do and
there might be very complicated to
figure that out but you at least knew
that was the strategy if God doesn't
exist how do I decide to lead a good
life it's great to say like that's what
I should try to do but you do we have
does it is there some immediately
following meta ethical strategy for
figuring out what makes a person good or
bad the first thing I would suggest is
that humanists and atheists need to move
away from outcome driven strategies
let's leave that to theists who have
divine assistance right that kind of
keeps things level for humanists and
atheists is just us
trying to do what we can and so we need
to move away from from strategies that
assume outcomes that hardwork and proper
thought will win the day and privilege
struggle like that in our very effort to
say no to injustice in its various forms
we might find something of our own
humanity it's not the outcome it's just
the process of saying no the process of
struggling against and so my answer to
that question would be we need to give
attention to strategies that that have
the potential to create the greatest
good ok aware that they might fail and
we might have to start this over again
right so it's not the same sense of loss
what happens if this strategy isn't
right that's an outcome driven
perspective we what we need to say is
well it may not be right we move on to
another one you know here in Las Vegas
if you're a poker player there's an
insult that people throw at you if
you're too results-oriented the wrong
thing but then you get lucky you can get
a good result but you shouldn't be too
happy with yourself play there is
randomness right right this is kind of
what you're saying like it's not about
the reward it's about the process
getting there but I saw you sneak in
there you have the greatest good this is
a utilitarian vocabulary there are
others who want to be virtuous or des
ontological would you call yourself
utilitarian in that way no not really
and I thought that might get popped by
you and and so for me I I see
inadequacies in that but at this point
thinking in terms of the greater good is
a strategy that's available to me I see
shortcomings with it but it's available
to me and and again not being outcome
driven just seeing process idea our
ability to say no to what we do
recognize this injustice and and so so
much of what we need to be doing and
thinking with respect to issues of
social justice involves negation I have
a sense of what and what a just world
can't look like yes okay and so you know
talk it wrong I know that is wrong I
know sexism can't get us there are no
racism can't get us there right it's by
negation right but okay I mean I think
that's right our present society is so
far away from utopia right that maybe
the details of which moral system is
perfect are less important than the fact
that we're nowhere near any of the right
potential perfections but even in the
journey right we can we're motivated by
thinking that well you know should we be
trying to just start everyone with a
level playing field and let them go like
almost a more libertarian kind of
strategy or should we provide some basic
safety net for everyone I think even
these more philosophical questions do
come down to practical issues a little
bit sure and my argument would be we
have to provide a safety net right we
have to provide some resource so that if
we don't provide some resource if we
don't take away the anxiety over basic
needs
we really can't progress all right you
have any closing thoughts words of
wisdom for the young humanists
secularists out there who wanted to be
more opening welcoming to other
communities you know I'm I continuously
have in the back of my mind the line
from the myth of sisyphus by Camus any
an ends that short essay with this one
must imagine Sisyphus happy so all we
can do is make the effort to improve
circumstances for life I couldn't agree
more in fact I quoted that line from the
myth of Sisyphus in my last book good
we're on the right track so Anthony Finn
thank you so much for joining me - thank
you
[Music]
you
[Music]